a gentle soul once advised us to be kind
to each other since every one of us is
fighting a hard battle and it's true the
trials and tribulations of everyday life
can be tough for us all but for octave
dad life as a husband and father who is
secretly an octopus poses unique
challenges ordinary tasks like making
coffee and mowing the lawn can be
difficult when you've got flailing
octopus tentacles instead of human hands
initially the juxtaposition of common
domestic situations with the gleefully
absurd concept that you are a sea
creature in a three-piece suit who has
somehow blended into human society makes
Octodad dadliest catch a delightful
comic romp
however as the game progresses it gets
away from its spirit of leisurely whimsy
with stealth sequences and boss battles
that don't play to the strengths of
octodad's goofy controls
simply walking around takes more focus
and Octodad than it does in your typical
game as you must hold the left and right
bumpers to raise your left or right legs
and then maneuver those legs around with
thumbsticks
it's almost impossible to walk around
and onto dad without knocking over
objects left and right and that's a big
part of the fun here you are an octopus
in a tuxedo on your wedding day
walking down the aisle making a complete
mess of things and yet nobody suspects a
thing
like walking around interacting with
objects is also a lot more complicated
for agha dad than it is for your typical
video game hero the fact that you use
one thumb stick to move your arm
horizontally and another to move it
vertically fills tasks like grilling
burgers and shopping for groceries with
the potential for hilarious physical
comedy
the early stages aren't challenging in
the least and this actually works in the
game's favor you can just relax and
laugh at yourself as your attempts to do
ordinary things are rendered anything
but ordinary by the fact that you are an
octopus but before long dadliest catch
loses its way despite octave dad's
burbled objections the family takes a
trip to the local aquarium octave dad is
terrified of the aquarium because the
marine biologists there with their
exhaustive knowledge of sea creatures
and their remarkable powers of deductive
reasoning can see through his carefully
constructed disguise you must sneak
around these marine biologists and once
the game starts actually demanding some
degree of physical prowess from you the
looseness and complexity that previously
made the controls fun to grapple with
suddenly makes them frustrating it's
hard to see the humor in a situation
when you find yourself failing it
repeatedly and applying trial and error
to find a path that might successfully
take you through a treacherous
environment additionally the activities
you have to complete at the aquarium
lack the domestic quality that makes the
first few stages so amusing
the game is at its funniest when it puts
the absurd Octodad in ordinary
situations it's a lot less funny when
the situation's he's placed in are as
absurd as he is they're also just aren't
enough situations in octave dad in
general you can easily complete the game
in about two hours and it ends up
feeling like an incomplete experience
that doesn't come close to fulfilling
its potential
octi dad is an endearing hero who's
struggled to live an ordinary life under
extraordinary circumstances can inspire
us all
but unfortunately Deadliest Catch is
just an inconsistent intermittently
hilarious trifle and not the game this
terrific character deserves